as you saw in the title I think the
rings of power so far is pretty
underwhelming now I'm not saying the
show is bad I think currently it's kind
of just all right the reason why it's
hard to dislike the show is that the
production value and spectacle is
immense almost every shot has a sweeping
Vista in the background that really
grounds us into this massive world even
scenes that don't really require to be
set in this setting like Aeron chilling
on a tree are and that really goes to
show the creators trying their hardest
to immerse Us in Middle Earth this feels
like Amazon spring out money like j-pal
pumping the economy full of cash but
because of this the scope to me is fully
realized and the massive budget
thoroughly helps in that regard I also
like the map transition shots where it
gives us a sense of the world's
geography and it's a good way to
transition from area to area for me I'm
not a major Lord of the Rings nerd and
have essentially just watched the movies
multiple times so I don't know all of
the lore and book material so going in
I'm not very familiar with all the
terrain politics and City so on the
basis of introducing the audience to all
of that it was a little overwhelming and
a lot of the dialogue was expository and
plot oriented to me that was by far my
biggest strike with the first two
episodes because when you primarily have
expository dialogue you don't allow a
lot of room for character developments
like so far I can't really pin that many
characteristics on most of the
characters that have been giving a lot
of screen time and even the characters
that were set up are pretty
stereotypical and don't have that much
depth to them like Nori being a
stereotypical kid who wants to break
tradition in his adventurous galadriel's
Vengeance obsessed and only wants to
kill oryx and then a reindeer is like a
walking robot from how expressionless he
is and even when he's with someone he
loves he's still very expressionless
which on the subject of a rundier dating
Bronwyn he said that he's been watching
over this territory for 75 years so
although we don't know if Bronwyn has
been in this area for most of her life I
hope that doesn't mean that aranzier has
known her since she's been a child child
and is now dating her because that would
be very weird and unsettling but we
don't know the details of their
relationship so let's get back to
talking about the character work so from
the fact that there isn't much character
development and the characters
themselves are pretty stereotypical they
come off so far as uninteresting most of
the scenes with them I'm finding myself
getting bored a bit as my eyes slowly
glaze over like the scene where Nori and
her friends are munching on berries was
almost pointless and the Wolf they
briefly show sniffing around better show
up again then we have elrond who didn't
have much to do in the first episode but
in the second episode his Dynamic with
Prince Duren was kind of interesting I
like the scenario of elves losing a
sense of time from their immortality and
missing certain aspects of immortal's
Lifetime it made for a good and genuine
conflict even though Dern was dragging
things out and it was acting like a kid
now in regards to the quality of writing
it feels very inconsistent I don't
outright hate it like some people do
because there are generally some quality
lines here and there as a few examples
there's I admire all who can see into
the mystery of things who can Divine
from the plainness of what is the beauty
of what could be where there is love it
is never truly dark for the same wind
that seeks to blow to fire may also
cause its spread these to me are pretty
good but again there's so much
Exposition it inherently drags down the
quality of writing within the same
sphere of characters we also have acting
and I also feel like it's pretty flawed
I touched on how OneNote Iran deer is in
his relationship with Bronwyn feels like
it has no chemistry so far but other
characters like elagerial and Nori feel
like they are over exaggerating their
performances in this scene with
Galadriel where she's talking to elrond
and starting to cut deep all she is
doing is holding the single wide-eyed
facial expression and there's two shots
that hold on it with no dialogue and it
felt really silly this in comparison to
raniera and House of the Dragon who
shows so many subtleties in her
performance blows galadril out of the
water and naturally I'm going to be
drawing comparisons between these two
shows since they're releasing at the
same time and they're both fantasies
then for Nori it's probably just our
character not necessarily her acting but
she is always in a constant state of
Amazement that it never allows for her
character to have a lot of range I know
she has an optimistic view of the world
but it is pretty exhausting when she is
always in that headspace because of this
I'm kind of just waiting for something
dark to happen to this character to
fundamentally change her world view and
thus make her more intriguing so as a
complete batch of characters it's not
impressive and if they all aren't that
interesting then you'll quickly lose the
audience because even if the plot is
good the show still needs to be
populated with characters to keep the
audience fascinated with the story and
for the rings of power the plot in of
itself is barely strong enough to hold
the attention of the audience as
evidenced by a lot of the exposition in
the first two episodes which I
understand that some of it is necessary
you just need to strike a good balance
and not make the exposition feel forced
and unnatural troll because when it
becomes clear that the writers are using
the characters a drone on and explain
things people will get bored moving into
another aspect that was surprisingly
pretty flawed was the editing because I
noticed three big mistakes and then
every now and then I would notice some
minor mistakes in different scenes
normally I wouldn't care if one mistake
slipped by the editing Bay but it became
kind of a recurrent issue I noticed on
three separate occasions that in the
wide shot you would hear the audio of a
character talking but visually their
mouth won't be moving I hear it said
that when you cross over you hear a song
this might not be noticeable for
everyone but for this example we can
clearly see that this character is not
talking Mighty sweet back of his well
the other day Margie sweet back of his
well the other day I don't know how this
can go unnoticed by so many different
people behind the scenes at Amazon
especially since each episode has a
budget of about 60 million dollars this
is not something I would have expected
to see in a blockbuster TV show and I'm
honestly kind of shocked these are
examples of me spotting wide shots of
people not actually talking but there
are also some other minor weird editing
choices like in this scene where
Galadriel and ailerons are talking on
this mountain there's a two shot of
galadra on elrond where elrond starts
talking but he's out of focus normally
in this type of shot you would rack
Focus to elrond which means the point of
focus would change from Galadriel to
elrond but he stays out of focus despite
him being the subject in a shot Who's
Talking Now this technically isn't
editing and is more cinematography but
it's still a weird choice if collateral
was giving more of her performance and
wasn't holding a single expression
during this shot then that could justify
the focus remaining on her but that
isn't the case they're in the same scene
there's a shot of galadra approaching
elrond as she's about to say something
but then it cuts to a top-down wide
shots the reason this doesn't make sense
is because you're setting up that she's
about to say something so therefore you
should hold a shot on her instead of
suddenly cutting away and these are just
something samples out of the two
episodes and on a larger scale this
really brings down the quality of
editing some people may not be able to
put their finger on why it feels off but
it's a lot of unconventional minor
editing mistakes that adds up over time
and again for a big budget show this is
kind of crazy to me
for one last aspect I want to look into
the brief amount of action that was
shown and that's primarily the troll
scene which was in the first 20 minutes
of episode 1 so spoilers for that scene
firstly the presentation of the troll
was amazing it being in the background
slightly obscured by Darkness creeping
around genuinely increased attention so
good job in that respect for building
suspense then for one more good aspect
the VFX of the troll was great it didn't
look off at all looked very high quality
and his integration into the environment
and the interaction with people looked
real with the budget of the show this is
to be expected but it's good nonetheless
but now we are getting into more of the
negative aspects the troll wrecking
people looked great however right-wing
Galadriel shows up the editing of the
scene immediately becomes jarring like
she's jumping around the troll slashing
at him but we can't really see the sword
connecting at all due to their framing
lighting and how fast it cuts away these
slashes are also supposedly severely
damaging the troll since he's
incapacitated after like three strikes
which in of itself is kind of weird
because shouldn't this big troll be much
more resilient than that also there's a
shot of galagel slashing the leg of the
Troll And while doing so the troll is
about to hit collateral but backs off
after his luck gets hit which that
doesn't make sense because why would her
hitting his leg force him to stop an
attack with his hands from this it seems
like the troll is suddenly nerfed so
that a galagel can curb stomp him and
come off as more of a badass when in
reality it immediately confused me as to
what the hell just happened and how that
event was so easy so the editing there
was a bit janky and looking at another
action scene which small spoilers
towards the end of episode 2 we have an
encounter with an orc and again the
editing was very quickly cut and felt a
bit jarring at times it wasn't so bad to
the point of it being incomprehensible
but it still wasn't very good however
the execution of the orc being really
strong and impacting the environment a
lot was really cool but so far it
doesn't scream 60 million dollars
episode levels of good overall the first
two episodes is primarily just all right
and I don't want to be overly harsh
because the character development could
come later on since they did a lot of
exposition in the first two episodes
something that I'm loving within House
of the Dragon is that they set up an
ensemble of great characters within the
same time the rings of power had and now
they're starting to ramp up the action
and plots of elements so in comparison
the rings of powers being outclassed to
bits thank you for watching and let me
know what you thought of the first two
episodes of the Rings of power
foreign